[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart Brandon from the
long now foundation late at tonight's
subject I thought I mentioned something
a little bit personal last couple years
people have been watching this they've
been noticing I'm losing weight and
there's a little alarm going on that I'm
wasting away like Steve Jobs there's
some indication says it's not the case I
have lost about 30 pounds over the last
two years and it correlates with going
twice a week to CrossFit which is kind
of strenuous and there's a lot of
Olympic free weight so I can deadlift
190 pounds that weight is going up and
my body weight is leveled off I went to
dr. the last month he had a full
physical full blood workup flying colors
across the board so I'm told Ronnie and
healthy
for now so if you're lucky enough to get
old there are a few kind of surprising
benefits that come with that one of them
is you get accustomed to the idea of
dying and you've probably seen your
parents go your cohort starts to thin
out you've seen friends fade and die in
many cases leave a crater of grief and
the family behind them and you become
acquainted with the details of mortality
and you get interested in learning that
there are people who really know the
stuff that goes on around whole process
that goes on around end of life and one
of the very best billows is a speaker
tonight Frank oestrus husky we'll start
with a video of his and then the man
talk to you
[Applause]
life and death are a package deal you
can't pull them apart
we cannot be truly alive without
maintaining an awareness of death death
is not waiting for us at the end of a
long road death is always with us in the
marrow of every passing moment she's the
secret teacher hiding in plain sight she
helps us to discover what matters most
and the good news is we don't have to
wait until the end of our lives to
realize the wisdom deaf has to offer
over the past 30 years I've sat on the
precipice of death with a few thousand
people some of them came to their deaths
full of disappointment others blossomed
and step through that door full of
wonder what made the difference was the
willingness to gradually live into the
deeper dimensions of what it means to be
human all of them were my teachers these
people invited me in to the most
vulnerable moments of their lives and
they made it possible for me to get up
close and personal with death and in the
process they taught me how to live
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm here we are
Thank You Stuart thank you for generous
introduction and for the kind invitation
to be part of the long now seminars we
love this series right I mean we just
yeah yeah well because we wrestle with
the big questions right we face the
really complex questions of our lives
the big issues of our day and and
there's no issue it's more important or
you know more complex or more mysterious
than our own death to imagine that at
the time of our death we will have the
physical strength the emotional
stability the mental clarity to do the
work of a lifetime is an absurd gamble
the time for that conversation is now
John Underwood is a wonderful guy he
he's the person who inspired the whole
deaf cafe movement that you've heard
about and he said something beautiful he
said we've outsourced discussions about
death to doctors and nurses priests and
Undertaker's the result is that we've
lost control of one of the most
significant events that we will ever
have to face in the past few decades
we've grown this big distance between us
and death you know we've made caring for
the dying unnecessarily complex we've
come to describe this remarkably
intimate activity of caring for one
another as a burden or task or an
obligation or duty I mean how did we get
there yeah
we've so professionalized it's so
mystified the dyeing process and the
care of the dying so we've come to doubt
our innate wisdom we've come to question
our innate capacity to do this but we
can do this this is in our bones we've
been doing this for thousands of years
with each other dying is not
predominantly a medical event and we
need to stop treating it as if it were
we need to bring the best of what
medicine has to offer to the care of a
dying but the experience of dying it's
too profound
to be fit into the medical model it's
too expansive to fit into any model
including most religious models the
encounter with death it opens us to the
deepest dimensions of our humanity in
this culture we tend to talk about death
as making the best of a bad situation
yeah that's how we talk about it with
each other and when we do that we
devalue dying and the people that are
going through it in absence of a more
meaningful conversation to many people I
think in our culture are dying in fear
and despair and I think we can do
something about that you know we talk
about America as being a death-denying
culture but it's not my experience
actually my experiences they were hungry
to talk about death we just don't know
how or we need somebody to talk with
about it who's not so frightened of the
subject it's where we have deaf cafes we
have this brilliant idea that Michael
heap created up in Seattle called death
of at dinner it's a fantastic idea
we have Monday nights in San Francisco
where we come to the jazz center to talk
about this we're hungry to talk about
this we want to talk about this we're
not destined I
look the whole world is running any
other direction running away from this
subject but for one reason or another
you've all come here tonight and I want
to applaud you for that
you've come and turned face to face with
the very subject everybody else wants to
run away from why how come so tonight I
want to think about our time together as
not so much introducing a bunch of new
ideas but rather remembering in a way
what we've forgotten because we forgot
we became frightened so rather than
providing answers or you know telling
you about the seven steps to a good
death you know I want to kind of extend
an invitation five invitations actually
to sit down with death to have a cup of
tea with her to get to know her really
well
and find out what she has to offer us
about living a more meaningful and
loving life in my experience when we
keep death very close at hand like our
fingertips you know what happens is we
don't hold on so tightly we let go a
little more easily and maybe we don't
take ourselves or idea so seriously and
I think what happens is we're kind of
doing another we understand that death
comes to all of us and so we're all on
the boat together and I think that
reflection on death causes us to be more
responsible in our relationships with
ourselves and each other with the planet
with our future a life that doesn't
include death it's only half a life
so look I'm not romantic about dying
this is the hardest work you will ever
do I don't have any woowoo like
California ideas about dying this is
tough
and it's it's it's sad and it's messy
and it's cool and it's beautiful
sometimes they're mysterious but above
all that it's normal its ordinary every
one of us are gonna go through this
process nobody gets out of here alive
yeah I mean maybe tonight but I'm not
making any guarantees hmm look over the
last 30 or so years I've set with a lot
of people it's out on the precipice of
death many many times with people and
most of them were ordinary folks people
like you and I coming to terms with
something that they imagined was
unbearable and yet they found within
themselves frequently and within the
process of dying the resources the the
strength the courage the compassion to
meet the impossible in extraordinary
ways that regularly happens I helped to
found a project here in San Francisco
called the Zen Hospice project it was
the first Buddhist Hospice in America
and we didn't know what we were doing I
mean we made it up as we went along but
I thought there was this natural match
between people who were cultivating what
I might call the listening mind or the
listening heart and meditation and
people who needed to be heard at least
once in their lives people who were
dying and so we just put them together
that's that was as much of a plan as we
had and in the beginning most of the
people we work with they lived on the
streets just outside here or in
Tenderloin hotels you know I changed a
lot of diapers on park benches behind
City Hall and these folks were they
lived on the edges on the margins of
society and they didn't trust much you
know and if I was gonna be of any use to
them I had to be clean
my intention and real yeah some of them
blossomed and it was beautiful you know
and they they discovered a kindness or
found forgiveness that they've been
looking for their whole lives but some
of them turned to the wall in withdrawal
and they never came back again yeah and
and all of them are my teachers there
was an en un vietnamese man who was
really afraid of ghosts and his roommate
was Isaiah and Isaiah was very very
comforted by visits from his dead mother
yeah there was a hemophiliac man that I
worked with who contracted the HIV
disease from a blood transfusion but the
year before he had disowned his gay son
who was living with AIDS yeah now we
were caring for the both of them father
and son both dying of AIDS in twin beds
in a single room being looked after by
Agnes who was her husband's wife and the
son's mother some of the people that I
worked with they they had beautiful
intact families you know and they had
good health insurance and they were
people of political power in San
Francisco some of them had deep faith
and others swarf religion years ago what
was true about all these folks is that
they didn't want nonsense they wanted
authentic relationships they wanted
somebody real to be with them some of
the folks I worked with died in their
early 20s yeah and then it was Elizabeth
I remember she was 93 years old and she
said to me
why is deaf come for me so soon and then
we say that when your teachers are in
the room they keep you honest yeah so
tonight I brought my teachers about a
hundred of them yeah and I'm gonna show
them to you in just a moment then these
are these are photos of people that I
worked with over many many years all of
which have died yeah now when I was
preparing for this talk that great
people that work with Stuart here said
could you send us your deck yeah I said
no it's attached to my house I can't do
that
[Music]
but I said I don't have a deck I said
but what I have or my friends and I'll
bring them with me yeah so um I brought
with me these photos and they're not a
video for you to watch passively and
they're not PowerPoint slides you know
these are real people inviting you to
learn from what they've encountered so
I'm gonna show them in just a minute but
I want to first encourage you to think
about bringing your attention to these
photos in a particular way did as you
listen to me also watch the photos and I
want to suggest that you keep 50 percent
of your attention in your own experience
you know you can listen to me with the
other part it's not that important
actually what happens in your experience
is much more important and you can
support that by sensing into your body
and your breath and really sensing the
messages that it's constantly sending to
you and when we contact our bodies what
happens is it gives us more access to
our emotional life and so we can stay
present also for the emotions that are
here the
tenderness or the love for the fear or
the tears or the grief that might emerge
for you I mean what would happen if
tonight while we're watching these
photos and listening to me you didn't
turn away from anything you're willing
to meet whatever came forward for you
and as we opened our body and heart you
know we expand to look at our minds you
know to really observe our minds walk
into the room of a mind and find out
what's going on there
you know the remembering or the planning
or the judging the comparing that might
be happening there and then I want to
encourage you to take one more backward
step we Sansthan take a backward step
and to settle back into the awareness
that can be cognizant of all of this
activity of body heart and mind and
settle into that so as you look at these
photos I want you to try and maintain
that self awareness through the whole
course of the evening yeah and and I
want you to ask two simple questions of
yourself what attracts me to the photo
and what causes me to pull away even if
slightly what attracts me and what
causes me to pull away and you know
track it see what happens and maybe
toward the end of the evening we can ask
you a little bit about that you could
share with us so Andrew let's put up the
slides now and let these happen and I'm
just gonna keep talking and keeping
company with these folks you know dying
is intimate is inevitable and intimate
and ordinary people people like you and
I they regularly develop insights into
their lives in the time of dying that
have them emerge as a much larger more
expansive more real person than the
small separate self they take in
themselves to be this is not a fairy
tale this is not a something that
contradicts all the suffering that's
also part of the dying experience it's a
transcendence
that tragedy and the discovery regularly
occurs for people in the final weeks or
days or some as moments of their lives
now you might say too late and I would
tend to agree with you it's too late but
the value is not in how long they have
that experience the value is in that the
experience exists and it exists at the
time of our dying it exists now yeah so
a while back I tried to consolidate or
develop a few simple ideas that shared
the wisdom that people are given me and
being with them around their dying and
so I developed these five practices I
called them more or five invitations
that for me served as reliable guides
ways to be with people and they're dying
and as it turns out they have a value
for the rest of us and leading a life of
integrity so I call them five
invitations and an invitation is a
request right to be present at a
particular event in your life well this
event is your life and what these
invitations are or an encouragement for
you to be present for every part of it
so the first invitation don't wait don't
wait that's the first invitation you
know waiting is full of expectation
waiting for the next moment to arrive we
miss this one waiting strategizing you
know about the future and what it holds
for us we miss the one at the moment
that's right in front of us I cannot
tell you how many times I've been with
family members who've said to me when is
mom gonna die and waiting for the moment
when mom dies they missed all the other
moments in between there was a friend of
mine he
he called me up and he said my mom is
dying and the doctors say she has about
six weeks to live
she lives in Toronto and he was living
here in San Francisco and he said that
when should I go and this is actually a
quandary a lot of us have we don't know
where families are miles and miles apart
sometimes so I said I don't know come on
over we'll talk about it so Tony came
over and we sat down and he told me a
bit about what the doctors had said and
then I asked him but about his mom and
he started to talk about his mom and as
he spoke about his mama they noticed
that his chin started to tremble a
little bit and that the color in his
face started to turn just a little bit
you know and I said I think you should
go tonight and he said I can't have
business tomorrow I have things to do
and I said well go tonight
and so he said okay and he took the red
eye and flew to Toronto and ten o'clock
in the morning he touched down in
Toronto at one o'clock in the afternoon
he was sitting with his mother when she
died don't wait if there's someone you
love tell them you love them mostly we
imagine death will come later
yeah and later it creates this
comfortable illusion of a kind of safe
distance but constant change
impermanence it's not later it's right
now change is the norm George Harrison
was right when he's saying all things
must pass this moment always is giving
way to the next you know everything is
vanishing right before eyes I mean I
used to have blond hair
and you know unlike Stewart gravity is
having its way with my body this isn't a
magic trick it's a fact of life and
permanence is the essential truth that's
woven into the very fabric of our life
and it's inescapable and it's perfectly
natural and it's our most constant
companion maybe you were like me I love
to lie in bed in the morning I do not
get up and exercise right away I like to
be there under the covers and the refuge
of my soft sheets and the warmth of the
morning you know and it's perfect and
life is great then right that's just
stunning
and then I have to pee right so I resist
for a while and then finally I get up
and I run to the bathroom and then I
come back you know having released all
of this tension and I get back into bed
and I pull the covers up around me
hoping to recreate the same perfect
conditions again and I can't do it I
can't do it intellectually we understand
that our mothers treasured vaz will one
day fall from the Shelf that our car
will break down that we will die but our
work is to move this understanding from
our intellect and nestled deep in our
hearts I was telling Stewart earlier
that in Buddhism the law of improvements
is called the law of change and becoming
it's not just lost it's not just
everything falls off the end of the
earth things are constantly dissolving
and becoming yeah we are at once here
and disappearing we rely on an
unimpaired minutes don't we I mean that
cold that you have you know it's gonna
go away
and that really boring dinner party will
eventually come to an end you know
and you know dictatorships will crumble
and be replaced I hope by thriving
democracies and even trees have to burn
down right for the forests to survive in
Japan right now right now this week
cherry blossoms are blossoming
everywhere yeah and I teach in Idaho a
lot outside the cabin where I teach
there are these blue flax flowers that
last for just one day why is it that
those flowers are so much more beautiful
than plastic ones yeah I think it's
because of the impermanence of them
they're ephemeral nature when we embrace
impermanence a certain grace I think
enters our life and we're free to savor
our life and you know whether that's
moments of great joy or of sadness we
become more appreciative and resilient
so at the heart this particular
invitation don't wait is reminding us
that the past and the future are stories
that the only place we can really live
is here now and encourage us to
encourage us to recognize that when
we're looking through a concept when
we're looking through a construction
we're losing touch with the immediacy of
our lives if we learn to let go into
uncertainty to trust that our basic
nature and that of the rest of the world
are not fundamentally different then the
fact that things are not solid and fixed
becomes a liberating opportunity rather
than a threat what becomes undeniable
when you're sitting with people who are
dying is that the fragility and the
impermanence or in the very nature of
life it's always coming together and
falling apart not just the physical
properties of life and not just at the
time of death and it's possible to hold
it all in love and compassion okay
second invitation welcomed everything
push away nothing sounds good right
we'll make a great bumper sticker no how
do we do it to welcome is to actually
confront us the word welcome even
confronts us it causes us to temporarily
suspend our usual rush to judgment and
it's a kind of invitation right to
welcome we don't have to like what's
arising and we don't have to agree with
it our task is just to meet what's
showing up at our door so when I suggest
that we become receptive to everything
everything that's present I don't mean
that we let life step on us that we
become a doormat not at all
acceptance is not resignation it's an
opening to possibility you know whenever
we fight with reality we lose that's my
experience whenever I fight with reality
I lose so when we're open and receptive
we have options we're free to discover
free to investigate for you to learn how
to respond skillfully to anything that
emerges you know the great
african-american writer James Baldwin
who I have such admiration for he said
not everything that can be faced can be
changed but nothing can be changed
that is not faced a few years ago I was
teaching retreat for doctors and nurses
on compassion and in the middle of that
retreat I had heart attack and this
resulted in a urgent surgery triple
bypass surgery and it was a big deal and
it was very humbling I used to think I
knew something about dying until after
my heart attack then I realized I didn't
know anything so this very famous
tibetan teacher he called me up when I
was at home recovering him and this
particular teacher he'd had his own
heart problems and so I asked him how
did you deal with it you know I said
he'd give me some esoteric prac
just like how'd you deal with it you
know the drama and the beauty and the
horror and the pain and all of it you
know the depression hmm was a pause on
the other end of the line and he said
well I think it's good to have heart and
he said if we have a heart below we
should expect it will have problems and
then he encouraged me to rest anything
up that was it and afterwards I thought
he's right you know if we have a human
life we should expect that we'll have
problems
where did we get the idea that it would
be otherwise so the one of the things
that being with dying has shown me is
the possibility of what happens when we
turn toward our suffering we're always
running in the other direction away from
any wax us in the back of the head you
know the healing is always found in the
middle of the suffering so that's the
place to go I was sitting in my office
one day and the phone rang this man on
the other end of the phone said our son
has just died
and we understand you could help keep
him at home and could you help us with
that nicely yeah I can do that so I went
to their house had never been I never
met this family before they I walked in
the door and went into the bedroom of
this young boy seven years old he died
of cystic fibrosis and following my
intuition I went over to the bed and I
leaned over and I kissed him on the
forehead and when I did this the whole
room broke into tears because while
everybody had cared for him with great
love nobody had touched him since he
died yeah and so this mom and his dad we
we talked about this ritual of bathing
the body that's been done for millennium
you know and every culture in every
religion so we talked about doing that
with their little boy him
and so they were great gardeners save
enough of the garden and they can mmm
sage and rosemary and lemon geranium
misson rose petals and we made a basin
of water you know these sweet herbs
flowers and then we started to bathe
this boy it was a hot fire they started
to remember at the back of his head and
he started to bathe him down this back
of his head in his neck and down his
back and this mom you know she was so
beautiful
she took care of every little scratch
and abrasion you know with so much love
sometimes it was too much for the dad he
couldn't do it and so he would just have
to go stand next to the window and look
out them to the garden you know this mom
kept washing down this young boy's body
and she got to his toes and she counted
his toes she said she'd done that when
he was born yeah how many of you have
parents in the room how many of your
moms or dads yeah we can't imagine this
right this mom would look at me
sometimes with these beseeching eyes and
she would say to me just in the silence
am I gonna survive this is it possible
to survive this can any mother survive
this and my job was to hand her another
washcloth you know we enter back there
son back to the suffering cuz that's
where the healings found in the
suffering she washed up the front of his
body and she'd stop once in a while he
she and her husband and they would tell
me stories about him you know took three
hours to wash this boy's body because
they had to keep stopping and telling me
about it and telling me about him so way
of getting current with the situation
where they were yeah
when his mom got to this boy's face I
was so tender between them so beautiful
she'd burned through a kind of grief and
I don't mean that her grief was over I
mean that that there was no separation
between this mother and child probably
like the moment in which he was born you
know the mothers in the room who have
breastfed their children you know this
you know what it's like
used to be one being yeah that's what it
was likely this mom and this boy
extraordinary we just him in his Mickey
Mouse pajamas and we invited his
brothers and sisters in the room and I I
asked them what they liked what did he
like to do more than anything and they
said oh he liked to build model
airplanes so he got all those model
airplanes so he made this mobile over
his bed you know so his brothers and
sisters could be part of this process
too yeah turned toward the suffering
when I went home that night I held my
son very very close he was 7 years old
at the time at the deepest level this
invitation is asking us to cultivate a
kind of fearless receptivity welcome
everything we shouldwe nothing it can't
be done as an act of will it can only be
done as an act of love yeah there's a
lot to being human much more than
getting born and getting an education
and finding the right partner and
getting a pretty house on a nice Street
so that you can sleep wake work go to
bed and do it all over again this is an
invitation to feel everything the come
into direct contact with this strange
beautiful horrible and often perfectly
ordinary thing we call life it's an
opportunity to be conscious of the fact
that some of us will make love while
others of us make war
and this week has really shown us that
it's to recognize the truth there are
babies like my granddaughter born into
loving arms caressed by a mother who
kisses a bright future into her cheeks
and there are people like my friend
Carolyn whose parents left her in a
dumpster and there are ways if it
reminds us to embrace the night screams
that happen in refugee camps and the
giggling of children in living rooms who
are making tents out of couch pillows
and bed sheets there is devastation and
there is hopelessness and there is
passion and the holy commitment to
create a better future for all of us
welcome everything push away nothing
third invitation bring your whole self
to the experience yeah we all like to
look good right everybody likes to look
good we want to be seen as capable and
strong and as intelligent or at least as
well-adjusted we like to project a very
positive self-image and few of us want
to be known for our helplessness or fear
or anger or our ignorance or sometimes
that were just much more of a mess than
we are letting on to the world yet more
than once I found the undesirable
qualities of my life the aspects of
myself that I most wanted to hide from
the world to be the very things that
allowed me to meet someone else's pain
and suffering with compassionate pity
when we care for others we think it's
our expertise that serves there's our
strength that serves I don't think so
you know I I have a lot of tools I have
a whole toolbox full of tools
but when I go into a room or someone's
dying I don't put that toolbox down
between me and the person and I'm seeing
one of us sure to trip over it so I
leave with my humanity and when I need a
tool I'll find it it's there in my back
pocket you know to be to bring our whole
self to be whole means to include to
accept and connect all the parts of
ourselves it's about accepting ourselves
as is my daughter's here we used to go
shopping in consignment stores you know
like crossroads or one of those you know
and and they're great you know because
you find these great finds in them you
know Paisley scarf or a cool leather
jacket or you know pair of sequined
heels or something like this you know
and so when she would be trying on
things I would peruse the rack so you
know I'd look for the next cool item
and in this one store we were in one day
I remember looking on this leather
jacket and there was a little cardboard
tag on it with the price on it
and then this really simple thing it
said as is as is and I thought we should
get those tags for ourselves in each
other
I take you as is is there a better gift
we could offer ourselves or each other
wholeness doesn't mean perfection
it means no part of us left out yeah so
years ago I was taking care of a friend
of mine his name was John and he was
dying of AIDS and there were about four
or five of us looking after him and and
there's one morning I came to his house
and overnight he had lost his ability to
stand to hold a fork were to speak in
any intelligent way what happened in one
night and I was sitting across the
kitchen table from him which was always
a mess at John's house and and I said I
couldn't find my friend I mean where was
he was just the other night before you
know and so we went through this day to
get it was my day to take care of him
you know and it was a lot of work you
know taking care of John it wasn't easy
and the day world into the night and the
night rolled into the early hours of the
morning John had these anal tumors and
constant diarrhea and taking care of him
was hard and I was tired and I was
cajoling and paternalistic and I treated
him like he was a child sometimes and I
just wanted for him to go to sleep and
to wake up in the morning and somehow
have this nightmare be over that's what
I wanted me mister Hospice yeah and so
I'm washing my hands went on in one
moment at the sink you know and I look
in the vanity mirror and John who's not
spoken all day it's whispering to me
he's sitting on the toilet with his
pajamas down around his ankles and he
says to me you are trying too hard
and I was trying much too hard to be
somebody you know me the caregiver me
mr. hospice yeah and I stopped right
with the middle of what I was doing and
I sat down next to it I just began to
weep I just cried on that moment you
know me and John and the bathroom [ __ ]
everywhere
it was the most intimate moment of our
whole friendship because in that moment
you see we weren't separate anymore
I've been afraid to go into the
territory where John was which was
helplessness I was afraid to go into
helplessness I was afraid that if I went
there we would get lost I would get lost
and I couldn't be of any use but there
isn't what happened what happened is
that when I sat there next to him the
situation showed us what to do next but
I couldn't have seen that before do you
see I had to be willing to go into that
territory bring your whole self to the
experience you know in the in the
Buddhist tradition compassion it comes
it's hooked up with wisdom and it's
particularly the wisdom that we're not
separate from each other
I mean we're each unique beautiful
beings I mean I wish you could stand
here and see the beauty that's in this
audience absolutely unique individual
but not separate no more than the waves
are separate from the ocean and it works
on this notion that there's we could say
two dimensions of compassion one we
might call universal compassion or
absolute compassion it's it's the
compassion that's always there it's
always been there everybody in and
everything has always been embraced by
this compassion even if we didn't know
it you know even if we were blind to it
and then there's everyday compassion
there's us doing stuff you know it's
changing soiled sheets or feeding
somebody or standing up against
injustice that's everyday compassion
right the everyday compassion is
exhausting I know
you know you start wanting people to
thank you for all the good things you're
doing and you get tired so it's got to
be sourced in something bigger than me
it's got to be sourced in something real
and that's universal compassion but
universal compassion it's just a big
idea it's just a big prayer and you know
if prayers were enough to stop the
suffering in the world we would have
stopped the suffering a long time ago so
universal compassion and everyday
compassion they need each other yeah it
needs our arms and legs it needs our
tongues and eyes to see the suffering of
the world and respond to it yeah and we
can only respond with compassion you
know if we know something about
suffering not much contact with
suffering that much compassion yeah I
was my I have a friend Bernie Glassman
he's a Zen teacher in New York and he
was teaching in Germany about this some
this figure in Buddhism called it a Balu
kita Schwar she's a feminist figure and
she has you've seen her she has a
thousand arms yeah and in each of those
arms and each of those hands there's an
ear an ear to hear the cries of the
world and a thousand arms to respond to
it was not a beautiful image yeah so
Bernie was talking about this in this in
this gathering and this man raised his
hand he said well it's a very nice
metaphor but I only have two arms what
should I do
and Bernie who was very kind said I'm
sorry you're mistaken and the man said
no I'm sure I have just these two arms
and then Bernie had everybody in the
audience raise both their arms go ahead
do it look around the house and arms
we can't do this by ourselves and we're
not alone the fourth invitation find a
place of rest in the middle of things
find a place of rest in the middle of
things most of us think we are too busy
and probably we are but also the way we
think about that topic matters you know
when I was in the third grade watching
that minute hand go around those big
round school clocks it took forever but
summer vacations lasted forever and now
there's never quite enough time what
happened was it same 24 hours same 24
hours and every day so this feeling of
not having enough time it doesn't align
with objective reality there's a Zen
story about a monk who's sweeping the
temple grounds you know and another monk
comes by in and kind of you know snips
at him and says too busy so busy like
that and the monk was sweeping he says
all you should know there's one who's
not too busy and what he was talking
about is that even in the midst of all
his activity there was some part of him
inside that wasn't busy at all yeah most
of us imagine that rest will come when
we go on vacation or when our inbox gets
empty or we check off our list yeah mine
list is never done my inbox has never
been empty yeah so if I wait for that
I'm in trouble
there was a woman it was at the hospice
her name was Adelle and she was I think
86 years old Russian Jewish women tough
as nails my father would say she was a
tough old broad and the night she was
dying they called me up and so I came to
see her I used to go all the time when
people were dying to be with them and I
walked in the room and I sat on the
couch in the corner that's
my way sit down find out if anything's
really needed before I jump in to help
and there was this mmm nurse's aide a
really great woman who was sitting next
to Adele you know and she turned to red
she said Adele you don't have to be
scared right we're right here with you
and Adele this tough cookie you know she
turned to her and she said honey if this
was happening to you you'd be scared so
I stayed in the corner a little while
later the the very nice well-meaning
attendant you know put a shawl over your
little cult would you like a shawl and
the dáil shot back of course I'm cold
I'm almost dead and I thought well I
hope I have half of the tenacity of this
woman when I'm dying yeah these are my
teachers these are my teachers so I
noticed a couple of things maybe you
even noticed in the story one was that
Adele was struggling there's a labor to
dying it's like there's a labor to
getting born and her struggle was
manifesting in the breath every
in-breath struggle every outlet struggle
yeah and this despite all the right
interventions of morphine and oxygen etc
it's a struggle to die and the second
was that she wanted no nonsense she
wanted real didn't want to talk about
tunnels of light or California woowoo
stuff or Bardot's or any of these things
she just wanted real someone reels to be
with her so I pulled on my chair and I
sat down right in front of her you know
and I said Adele would you like to
struggle a little less she said yes I
said okay I said I noticed something I
noticed just there at the end of your
exhale just before the next inhale there
was this little gap and I wonder what
it'd be like if you put your attention
there for a minute now remember this is
a 86 year old Russian Jewish lady she
doesn't care beans about Buddhism or
meditation or any of these things but
he's highly motivated in this moment to
be free of suffering
so I said I'll do it with you so there
we weren't breathing together she would
read him I would breathe him so you'd
read out I have a breathe out yeah just
like that nothing simple I mean nothing
fancy just simple didn't guide her I
just breathed her there and as you could
see her sort of put her attention in
that gap you know that little pause
there that little nanosecond and then
she did you could just see the fear in
her face just drain away and she laid
back on her pillow she said thanks and a
few minutes later she died very
peacefully
I think Adele found the place of rest in
the middle of things understand that I
mean all the conditions were the same
she was still dying there was difficulty
breathing it was still all the stuff the
hubbub but she found a place of rest
right in the middle of it where do you
find the rest yeah find a place of rest
in the middle of things you know the
easiest place to to know this is in our
own breath right just to become mindful
for a moment of our own breathing after
my heart attacks after the surgery
rather it was a long surgery maybe 12
hours or something like this and I was I
was wheeled into the CCU you know
intubated tubes coming out of every
orifice morphine pumping into one arm
something else pumping at the next arm
you know machine breathing for me I was
very disoriented and and into the my son
was with me here tonight
my son was of me and my best friend
Eugene who's a meditation teacher he was
with me and we were there and I'm kind
of foggy and this respiratory therapist
walks in the room and he said let's pull
out that tube and see if you can breathe
and I was like I could feel there was
something wrong with my lung and it was
something wasn't right
you know I could just feel it you know
and so I wrote on a pad I'm scared and
my friend Eugene who's a really
level-headed meditation teacher he said
Frank find your breath and so I tried to
but I couldn't tell the difference
between the Machine and my own breath
and then he said since your body sent
your body and I tried but I could only
feel my body up to about my knees there
was still anesthesia and all that stuff
going on you know I was scared and then
I remembered Suzuki Roshi
you know just up the block from here is
the San Francisco Zen Center in Suzuki
where she started he was this shy
wonderful ferocious actually Zen guy
Japanese man who in ten years changed
the face of Zen in America but the night
before he was dying Suzuki Roshi the
great meditation master he said I want
to take a bath and his wife discouraged
it but his son out the hero filled the
bathtub and picked up his father and he
carried him to the bathtub and he
lowered his father down into the bath
water
and as he did Suzuki Roshi got terrified
he was afraid he was drowned yeah and I
remembered this when I was in the
hospital and I thought if Suzuki Roshi
can be scared I can be scared
yeah my son put his hand on my chest I
remember it was like a conduit from God
yeah and Eugene he I pulled him really
close to me and I put my ear against his
cheek and so for a while I just followed
the rhythm of his breath until I could
find my own again I borrowed his breath
until I could find my own find a place
of rest in the middle of things
it's not about managing all the
conditions okay last invitation fifth
invitation cultivate don't know mind now
I felt obliged to put something zen-like
in this list hmm my son used to say to
me dad what the hell does that mean you
know the cultivate don't know mine is
not an encouragement to ignorance you
know ignorant is not just not knowing
anything says we know something but it's
the wrong thing yeah ignorance is
misperception don't know mine represents
something entirely different it's it's
it's beyond knowing and not knowing
altogether it's off the charts from
either of those don't know mind is
characterized by curiosity by wonder by
our by surprise you ever watch a kid you
know my granddaughter I like to play
hide and seek with her every time I do
it she's surprised and she loves it yeah
it's totally fun being surprised
give me threw a surprise party for an
adult huh you know they walk in the room
and they say who's responsible for this
you know
yeah so so Donal mine is a mine that's
ready that's open that's free it's an
invitation to empty with fresh eyes to
empty our minds and open our hearts yeah
that night before my surgery my son and
I were having this really great
heart-to-heart talk you know and I love
my son and we were talking about this
and that and then he in the middle of
this conversation he said dad are you
gonna live through this but took me back
you know independent you know I'm the
dad so I want to say of course no
problem easy got it and so I started to
say that out of my mouth I heard myself
say I'm not taking sides yeah and it
really surprised me I mean I wasn't
trying to be Buddhist or sage or
anything like that I just in that moment
I wasn't taking sides with life or death
you know and then they talk about
enlightenment and awakening and
realization all these fancy words you
know they don't seem really far off to
me and people are trying to achieve them
and then when they get to them they can
have some you know transcendental moment
where they can float beyond all the
troubles of the world I don't see it
that way a better word for me is
intimacy you know that when I said I
need calm I practice mindfulness
practice anymore I just call it the
practice of intimacy learning to be
intimate with myself in the world you
know and then there's another teaching
that's related to this it says you know
the path is right beneath your feet in
other words it's right here right now
dying is not something at the end of the
long road so the intimacy of don't know
mind is the encouragement to connect
with life with the sound of the birds
with spring breeze you know with this
very life with the truth of what's here
we could say with the sacredness of life
now that's a tough word for a lot of us
sacredness but for me the secrets not
something separate or different from the
rest of life but it's rather it's
something is hidden in the middle of
life and in the dying process
the blind process is stripping away
process and what it does is it reveals
the sacred reveals the sacred rites in
hospice we had a unit at Laguna Honda
Hospital it's just down the road and you
know it's the nation's largest public
long-term care facility 1,100 beds
they redid it recently but in when we
were there look like this
that's Laguna Honda that picture one
room with 30 or 40 beds to a room
everybody in those beds are dying that's
where we were it's like our worst
nightmare in America right no privacy
but actually it was pretty remarkable
because people saw other people dying
and they saw that they weren't left
alone that they weren't in under
intractable pain that they were cared
for beautifully anyway I was walking
down this gauntlet of beds looks like
that one day and there was this older
african-american man and he was sweating
up a storm and so I went over and I sat
down in the chair next to him and and I
said to him you look like you're working
really hard that's my way of being with
people and he said yeah just gotta get
there and he pointed like that
and I said oh I said if I promise to
come if I promise to keep up can I come
and he said yeah and he grabbed my hand
now this man was actively dying and I
said him I didn't read my glasses I
can't see their into the distance can
you see and he described for me a
sloping hillside to a kind of plateau I
said you want to go yeah okay let's go
and we walked up this hillside now he
was pale huffing and puffing and panting
you know sweating up a storm when we got
to the plateau I said can you see there
further into the distance and he said
yonni
he described for me a little one-room
red schoolhouse with three steps on the
door this is a man who been raised in
Mississippi now I could have said to him
at this time you're disoriented times
three this is result of the morphine and
the brain metastases but none of that
was true well he's true as we were
walking into a little red schoolhouse I
said you want to go in yeah
can I go no I said okay then you go and
a few minutes later he died very
peacefully see the sacred snot about
seeing something new it's about seeing
things in a new way
yeah letting go is the doorway to this
understanding but the way we normally
think about letting go is it implies a
kind of release or distancing ourselves
from a person or situation or an object
or some kind of limitation and it's a
company usually when we let go by some
sense of freedom from previous
constrained but surrender is more about
expansion there's a freedom to it but
it's not about setting something down
you're free of it because you're no
longer defined by the limitation and
that's what can happen in the time of
dying we become larger than the one who
was previously enslaved to this
limitation transformation is a deep
internal shift through which our basic
identities are reconstituted it's a
process of transformation where the
scales kind of fall from our eyes and we
see our experience in a new way in the
tradition that I come from Buddhism the
reflection on death is not an ideology
that we adopt to protect ourselves
against death rather it's an opportunity
to become more intimate with death with
its inevitability but also so that it
might not it's not a morbid reflection
it's a way of bringing us more
intimately into contact with our life so
that we can see what's important right
here right now the five invitations are
a call to transformation they can take
you to the threshold but then you have
to walk the rest of the way there's a
beautiful quote by Rumi it says that out
the door is round and open don't go back
to sleep the door is round and open
don't go back to sleep
there was a woman in her hospice her
name is sono slid down the street and
she stayed with us for a couple of
months this is her I got so low that
picture was taken two hours after she
came into the hospice tough cookie two
hours
that's so no two hours after she died
how do we get from that to that I think
in part we take the time to look at our
life to reflect on our life to see what
has meaning and value and purpose and we
need someone to share that with we get a
chance to tell our stories and mmm
articulate what's important to us write
it down sometimes we are accompanied by
compassionate companions people who
aren't afraid to love us or are
suffering yeah how do we get from that
to that Sona and I were sitting in the
kitchen one day into the kitchen and I
was reading a book of Japanese death
forms and Japan there's this tradition
that on the day of your death you write
a poem that tells the essential truth of
your whole life yeah oh wait you have to
be for that
and I think if you don't die that day it
doesn't count you have to write a new
one the next day yeah
so I was I was reading this book of
death Homs and Sona said what are those
and I told her about it and so she said
well read me one so I read her codons
famous one
it says empty-handed I entered the world
barefoot I leave it my coming my going
to simple happenings that got entangled
yeah yeah beautiful so we're talking
about this this tradition she said I
want to write one of those and I said
okay great you should write one
she said that well how what's the form
how do you do it I said don't worry
about the form just graded so she left
her room and on three hours later I got
summoned to her room she didn't ask me
to come he told me to come and I went
into a room and I sat down she said I
wrote my death poem Frank and I want you
to learn it by heart she didn't say I
want you to memorize it he said I want
you to learn it by heart I want to know
they're losing your soul so I said okay
so no I'll do that she made me learn it
right there you know it took took me a
while because I must learn her she said
and when I die I want you to pin it to
my bed cloth and I want to be cremated
with it you see that poem that's her
poem that's Ana's gift I'm gonna hear it
yeah this is a woman who lived on the
streets here this is the woman you walk
by every day and don't notice she said
don't just stand there with her hair
turning gray soon enough the Seas will
sink your little island so while there
is still the illusion of time set out
for some other Shore no sense packing a
bag you won't be able to lift it into
your boat so give away all of your
collections
take only new seeds and an old stick
send out some prayers on the wind before
you sail don't be afraid someone knows
you're coming in extra fish has been
salted yeah don't just stand there with
your hair turning gray soon enough the
Seas will sink your little island so
while there is still the illusion of
time set out for some other Shore no
sense packing a bag you won't be able to
lift it into your boat give away all
your collections take only new seeds and
an old stick that's a beautiful image
isn't it you think of farmers stick seed
stick seed stick seed in solos my dying
was not a final stop it was a time of
growth take only new seeds in an old
stick and send up some prayers on the
wind before you sail the other ways
don't think you can do this alone
it's a mouthful be with people who know
things don't be afraid someone knows
you're coming
in extra fish has been assaulted thank
you so no thank you
[Applause]
all right we'll pulsing her ass why do
you refer to death as sheep politically
correct or is there some hidden message
no I think that most of our images of
death are you know the grim reaper and
then some you know terrible being was
coming to grab us you know and I think
death is more soulful from that soulful
than that I think that so when I called
her she I just thought of the soul
fulness of the feminine receiving us as
opposed to taking us Matt asks how do
you and sure you bring children into the
conversation about that this is
something that can wait until it's
personally relevant to them what well
it's it's a good really good question
thanks man and years ago before I did
this work in hospice I had a preschool
where for kids that were three to five
years old my son was part of that and we
used to have these days they would take
the kids out into the woods and find
dead stuff and they loved it you know
kids are really curious you know so so
we go out in the woods and we'd find
dead stuff and they would you know bring
it back and put it on this big blue tarp
and they would smell it and taste it and
touch it and get really close to it you
know and they had the most remarkable
experiences they would they would talk
about this stuff was like show-and-tell
you know they would talk about these
things like they'd find a rusty old car
part and say what fell from space from a
passing spaceship and you know this one
girl talked about this piece of bark
that had been a bed for a mouse they no
longer needed it and then there's one
little girl she said something beautiful
she said I think the trees are very
generous
she said the leaves that fall are very
generous
they make room for new leaves to grow so
I think having a straightforward
conversation with kids is important and
not not giving them more information
than they need you know when I was
driving down the road in our town where
this guy grandpa Tom used to live in and
my son said that's grandpa Tom's house
my son's five years old and I said yeah
and then he said are you gonna die
I said yeah someday thanks said dad is
mom gonna die
I said yeah someday we'd go further down
the road and then he said am I gonna die
I said yeah someday and that's only
needed he didn't need me to make it
better or to tell him a fanciful story
about it
he just wanted to know just the facts
ma'am just the facts a lot of times
which comes up with yeah I think it's a
really great opportunity to get kids up
close and personal with the experience
and and also not just with the death of
the pet but with their own feelings you
know like we're somehow afraid that
children should have full feelings you
know that they'll feel the fullness of
sadness or the fullness of fear I think
if there's a holding environment if the
parents are that holding environment
that the child can experience all those
things without getting lost in it yeah
they've talked about mostly so far is
the person doing the dying yeah and in
some ways they're grieving about their
own guy but there's a lot of people
around them there's caregivers
family there's a whole grief well yeah
see about that I think it's I think it's
really tough Stewart you know like we
have a lot of models about grief in this
culture we've got bereavement models and
all kinds of you know seven steps to get
us through it and I don't believe in any
of them actually I think that it is
fierce grief and you know it's a whole
spectrum of experiences that might
include sadness and fear and and but
also relief you know after you've been
caring for someone you love for months
there's relief in grief
laughter sometimes it sure absolutely
it's a funeral yeah and there's numbness
you know which people think is no
feeling but it's a feeling of its own
numbness and you know sometimes our
grief is about what we've had in lost
and sometimes it's about what we never
got to have you know and it doesn't stop
you know like if my wife dies she's the
one who kept the bed warm and when I
come into bed at night I lose her again
I don't just lose her once I lose her
many times yeah I've had CEOs of
companies that were brilliant but they
were eating tuna fish for dinner because
they didn't know how to fill that role
for themselves somebody else in their
family had done it for them and part of
the grief was part of working with the
grief was helping them to figure out how
to make a meal you know so yeah I think
that you know in the old days when
people were grieving they used to wear a
black armband right yeah they Norfolk
for a period of mourning because you
know what it said was look I am in an
altered state here do not expect me to
behave normally
you know I need help you know I can't do
the daily activities the way I used to
do them and so the whole village would
look after that person and care for them
until that period of mourning was you
know seemingly coming to some kind of
conclusion I mean in the Jewish
tradition when you sit Shiva
you know you come into the house you
cover all the mirrors and clock and you
sit Shiva you sit for a week and you
take your cue from the family you know
if they're telling a joke you laugh but
the really important thing about that
whole practice is that at the end of the
week you go out and you walk around the
village or you walk around the block
yeah to demonstrate to somebody that a
certain period of mourning is coming to
a close and you're ready to reenter the
world yeah we've lost touch with some of
these rituals and I want to bring them
back question what is your perspective
on unexpected death
totally differently you know like the
shock and the denial and the you know
the this belief is phenomena you know at
that point and so you know the best
thing you can do with your with someone
who's going through the grieving a loss
like that is just hold their hand and
and you know bring them food and help
them fill out the insurance forms and
and understand that it will take time
for that loss to be assimilated and to
be metabolized yeah Danna Grady David
Grady degree that's real great yes how
can we help those newly diagnosed with
incurable dementia a face impending
diminishment loss itself thing I mean we
you know were talking about this earlier
that you know this is tsunami coming
that we are totally unprepared for I
mean one in one in ten adults over 65
have Alzheimer's the most common cause
of dementia over eighty five thirty two
percent of those people have Alzheimers
right right now in this country there's
I think forty nine thousand people
living without simmers the expectation
is that within the next ten years if we
don't change something about this we'll
have seventy million people living
without summers and this is a first
world disease in other words people in
third world nations are not living long
enough to get out summers but they will
they will that's right so this is real
and we are completely unprepared yeah so
you know there's all kinds of things
that we need to do as a culture to you
know respond to this massive epidemic
which is by the way dwarfing the HIV
epidemic I mean there's 70 million
people in the world with HIV now about
half of those people have died all
summers is going to leave that in the
dust
for the increasingly fading the banjee a
person you know it's confusing for us to
be around somebody who's confused we get
confused and so you know I think it
helps us to see that memory is a good
cousin to truth but not its twin yeah in
other words memory is always reforming
right we only remember the last time we
remembered something that's what we
remember right
so our even our a notion of some kind of
objective reality he's always changing
anyway it's just that it's we agree on
it so when I'm with people who are
suffering from dementia I try to
remember that there's a whole human
being there you know my aunt was 86
years old without Sanderson and when I
went to see her she'd be throwing her
dress over her head you know and calling
me by other name she always thought it
was somebody else and I would just be
with her you know and one day I got
curious I said Mimi all these years you
know you never had a sweetheart you
never had a beau cuz she never got
married you know and she sat up in her
chair like this folded arms she said
some questions are too personal to ask
where'd that come from I don't know but
that mystery keeps me looking keeps me
really wanting to continue to see the
person with dementia as a whole human
being and not just as their condition so
do you have conversations with them as
if there's a hole in there absolutely
and there is you know I mean we're
pretty identified with our brains you
know we're not so identified with our
spleens right
I mean so if our brain starts to go we
think oh there's nobody there you know
oh there's no value to this life oh why
we don't say that about our spleens you
know there's a whole human being there
this organ is not functioning but this
is still all there's a whole being there
that can still receive our love can
still feel touch can you know watch this
beautiful film that's out there called
alive inside maybe you've seen it it's
about a social worker who starts playing
music for people with Alzheimer's and
serious dementia and they come alive
they don't their dementia doesn't go
away but they're there the ability to
appreciate life steps comes forward yeah
so yeah there's a whole human being
their physician assisted suicide
basically checking out yeah yeah you
know for a long time I mean I haven't
been in a program where somebody hasn't
asked me this question and and for a
long time I didn't necessarily share a
view because I wanted the culture to
wrestle with it actually I didn't want
him I didn't want to be the expert
single okay this is the right answer
and and I still feel that way actually
but the culture is wrestling with it you
know we have now five states where
physician-assisted death by the way not
suicide that's how we think about it
it's legal California just approved it
in in Oregon which is the state of most
familiar with and has the best data
Barbara Coombs Lee and I sat down for
hours in her office one day
talking about this subject she wanted me
to be on their national board and I
wanted to get informed him so here's the
stats 20 it's been 1997 the Oregon law
got past 20 years we've been doing this
fifteen hundred and forty five people
have applied for prescriptions to end
their life
nine hundred and ninety one I think have
actually taken the medications
that's about forty nine people a year
that means that thousands of people have
wanted information got it directly or
indirectly over twenty is fifteen
hundred or so of them have actually
gotten the medications but only nine
hundred have taken the medications that
tells me two things one is it's really
reassuring for people to know that they
can do this
the hospice referrals in Oregon
skyrocketed pain and symptom management
is better there than it's ever been I
think that having the comfort of knowing
that I can use this option if I want to
it helps a lot of people to stay with
their experience and actually not choose
that option but in fact stay with the
experience although through their dying
process because just in a sense the big
choice is opening up all these other
choices
yeah I have agency I'm not a victim to
this experience and so now that I have
agency I can step into this experience I
can I can put both feet in I can be
engaged in this and see what it has to
teach me you know from the plant adjourn
now we say oh I would never well when it
comes to that point that'll be too much
but we don't know what it's gonna be
like in that moment I mean my experience
is our habit to live is really strong I
mean don't enter estimate this
instinctual drive you have to live and
my experience is that when people are
surrounded by good care when they have
proper you know pain management a
symptom control and they're loving
compassionate people around them they
feel the support not just to get through
the experience but to use the experience
as an opportunity maybe the greatest
opportunity
transforming their lives so it's called
physician-assisted so i think the names
do for the physicians for the medical
profession to have this is yeah well of
course in the beginning it was difficult
for a lot of docs you know some Doc's
had religious and other kinds of moral
you know views about this but the
reality was it was always going on it
just was going on under the radar
yeah my father got extra morphine hey
you know the country doc used to do this
all the time he would make the decision
on his own you know for Grandma or for
auntie Joan you know it used to happen
all the time I was in the AIDS epidemic
you know it happened a lot in the AIDS
epidemic yeah I came up on that epidemic
but now what we're doing is making it
much more informed consent about it some
country doctor isn't deciding for me I
get to decide the the government isn't
managing my experience I get to decide
and again that gives me a sense of
agency and I think the possibility of
meeting the experience and entirely
different wedding I'm not advocating for
this as the option that people should
choose this option we have this notion
of the law in Oregon is called the Death
with Dignity Act and I hate this name
it's like Death with Dignity Max and I
could decide what's dignified I mean who
gets to decide this somebody the person
gets to decide this not somebody looking
in not whether her nail polish is done
that isn't Death with Dignity I've seen
people in horrible conditions Express
the greatest dignity I've ever witnessed
you know it had nothing to do with how
they looked or the conditions of their
life in that moment it had to do with
you know the the basis of their humanity
coming forward you know their true
humanity coming forward yeah we tried
quote on you see what do you think about
it this is from a novel written in 1965
by John Williams is called the stoner
it's about a very boring seeming kind of
classics professor in the Midwest
and it's become a hit novel lately
Europe and elsewhere and in there the
character is being described by the
authors he wondered again that the easy
graceful manner in which the Roman
lyricist accepted the fact of death as
if the nothingness they faced were a
tribute to the richness of the years
they had enjoyed and he marveled at the
bitterness the terror that barely
concealed hatred he found in some of the
later Christian poets of the Latin
tradition when they look to that death
which promised however vaguely a rich
and ecstatic eternity of life as if that
death and promise were a mockery that
soured the days of their living mmm-hmm
it's a beautiful passage it's a hell of
a thing yeah it's a you know once the
afterlife is sorted there is some kind
of judgment or something what's going on
with it so spooky here I know you know
we got so many stories about what
happens after we die and I don't know if
any of them are true I mean I've been
with a lot of people and they've told me
all kinds of things but you know I'll
find out you know my father used to say
it can't be so bad because nobody's come
back to complain but but you know talk
to the Buddhists about that you know
I mean here's what I think about this I
think that that everybody has a story
about what happens after we die
everybody I mean we got it maybe when we
were kids as part of our religious
training or cultural training or family
stories the story changes absolutely
religion but what do you get when you
lose ability you lose one story what do
you get and you create a new one
oftentimes well we had a guy who was the
president of the California atheist
Association come and die with us at Zen
Hospice I was very proud that he feel
comfortable to come back and and so we
had these conversations I always had
these conversations with people I say
what do you think's gonna happen after
you die and he would say nothing and I
said well what do you mean nothing like
will you have a nose we have ears we
hear things
no no so I said I said well you know
what's it gonna be like there's nothing
is it like a dial tone you know she said
no it's not a dial tone
I said what's it like he said well come
on I should tell me why he said he said
well it's like your molecules and you
mix with all the other molecules in the
universe
that's what nothing is like I said oh
that kind of nothing I thought he was
gonna be okay you know
no I had another guy this guy Jackie I
met Jackie on Hayes Street actually
Jackie was a thirty year heroin user
black man he's staying at the Zen
Hospice and I said hey Jackie I see here
on his Buddhist hospice I said you think
you couldn't get born again this is how
I have conversations with people and I
probably make our lousy therapist
he said yeah I'm gonna get born again I
said well what are you gonna come back
ass he said Jackie I said boy you want
to be Jackie you know and you could be
you know like in some cultures you could
be a cow and that would be really good
you know very spiritual or you could
come back as a king or a queen or
something like that you know I said you
know what you think come back as a cow
you said I'm not coming back into a
goddamn cow I'm coming back as Jackie I
said why
how come it's because next time I'm
gonna get it right and we went to a
whole nother conversation here yeah like
now so ask this question of people find
out don't try and talk him out of their
belief systems you know they I had this
grandma she was a Christian Scientist
she was so ready to die ninety years old
she just wanted to lay herself in the
lap of Jesus and her granddaughter came
to see her you know and very
well-meaning she said grandma you know
when you die you don't have to worry
because everybody who's died before
you're there gonna be there to meet you
and they'll be there they'll they'll
welcome you you know and grandma became
terrified yeah
yeah because the secret that she never
told her family which she told me was it
Edgar her husband who had died five
years before I've been beating her most
of her life and now the idea of spending
eternity with him was terrifying to her
so I don't impose my ideas on other
people I find out from them what's true
for them and I see how I can support
that but I don't try and give him my
beliefs you know well I'll figure it out
I'll make the last question from Kevin
Kelly yes food technologist could
eradicate death as mandatory yeah would
you celebrate or mourn oh that's a good
question s what about it well it's an
interesting idea Kevin you know June
Eunice is working on this down in the
hedge fund guy down there and dr. now
he's working on hacking aging and it
seems to me that even if you know a we
live for a very very long time at some
juncture
there'll be an ant at least an end to
the way we know things but honestly I
don't really think about just death that
happens at the end I think about the
impermanence that characterizes this
life that even if we live for a long
long long long time impermanence will be
a central aspect of that life so I could
imagine that as people start dealing
with his living centuries they
reinvented a version of yeah they died
their previous story so far and lived
into it from a butterfly to a
caterpillar and whatever the hell it may
be but that's a way to manage long
survival yeah I mean I was I was
teaching in New York at NYU and and this
cardiac physicians and the guy said well
I'm not sure that death is inevitable
there's a cardiac physician you know I
thought man now what's it like to be
with you as the doctor yeah
see I don't see it I'm not in a battle
against death mm-hmm I don't think that
it's our enemy I don't think you know
more time is necessarily better I mean
there are some wise old people like
yourself you know but there's some
people around we're not so wise and I've
lived a long long time so for me it
matters how do I step into this life
like how fully do I live this life how
completely do I love the people I love
you know not how long do I get you know
quality over quantity that's my view
[Applause]
[Music]